PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
A MUD-FILLED OBSTACLE COURSE
WAS A WALK IN THE PARK
FOR LISA --
WAY TO GET STARTED, GIRL!
AND HER EXUBERANCE PAID OFF
AT THE GO-SEE THAT FOLLOWED.
THE ONE THAT WE PICKED
WAS LISA --
AH!
AS THE WINNER
OF THE CHALLENGE
AND KIM TURNED UP
THE SEX APPEAL IN A '40s-ERA
PINUP PHOTO SHOOT.
THAT'S A NICE ONE.
THAT'S GOOD.
WHILE KYLE CAME ACROSS
AS TOO CONVENTIONAL
FOR A TOP MODEL.
YOUR IDEA OF MODELING IS --
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
THANKS, KYLE.
SIX GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE
ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪ I WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪
♪ YOU WANT TO BE ON TOP ♪
KYLE MAIL.
IT SAYS "KYLE MAIL."
OH.
I DON'T KNOW
IF I CAN READ THIS.
I'M GONNA CRY,
BUT I'LL READ IT ANYWAY.
LAST ELIMINATION
WHEN IT WAS DOWN TO KYLE
AND BRE, KYLE WAS ELIMINATED.
THANKS, KYLE.
"ALL MY GIRLS,
I LOVE YOU GUYS SO MUCH.
I'M REALLY SAD TO LEAVE,
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT A WHOLE
PIECE OF ME WILL BE MISSING.
I WISH ALL OF YOU
THE BEST OF LUCK."
I MISS KYLE SO MUCH.
I KNOW SHE'LL BE OKAY.
BUT I JUST -- I DON'T KNOW
HOW I'M GONNA BE OKAY
WITHOUT HER HERE.
THE HOUSE IS SO LONELY
FOR ME WITHOUT HER.
I DON'T THINK I'M GONNA DO WELL
WITHOUT HER AT ALL.
WELL, JUST PRAY FOR ME.
OKAY, I'LL PRAY EXTRA HARD.
LAST WEEK IN ELIMINATION
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO.
WILL BRE AND KYLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
WITHIN THE NEXT FIVE WEEKS,
I SWEAR I'M LIVING EVERY DAY
LIKE IT'S MY LAST DAY HERE.
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO
IS JUST BE POSITIVE
AND JUST DO YOUR BEST.
YOU CAN'T
DO NO MORE, NO LESS.
SO WHAT AM I GONNA DO --
QUIT OR AM I GONNA TAKE IN
EVERY MOMENT
AND USE IT TO MY ADVANTAGE?
EVERYONE'S GONNA TRY
TO ERASE MY PICTURES.
PEOPLE ERASE PICTURES OF ME.
AND THAT'S NOT COOL.
SO I'M PRINTING THEM OUT.
I THINK, SLOWLY BUT SURELY,
I THINK I'M BECOMING MORE
OF A THREAT
TO THE OTHER GIRLS.
AND THE GROUP HAS GROWN
SO LITTLE, THAT I THINK
PEOPLE ARE JUST GETTING MORE
AND MORE INSECURE
WITH THEMSELVES.
TYRA MAIL.
HAVE YOU EVER THOUGHT WHAT IT
WOULD BE LIKE TO BE A DIVA?
BE READY AT 11:00 A.M..
EVA AND DIVA.
OH, DAMN.
EVA.
OH!
THIS IS SO UNREAL.
THE SECOND I WAS LIKE,
"OH, MY GOODNESS,
WE'RE MEETING EVA."
EVERYONE WENT CRAZY.
I GOT TO
LOOK GOOD TOMORROW!
I GOT TO DO MY HAIR!
I'M GONNA LOOK GOOD TOMORROW!
SO I'M LIKE,
"I'M SO READY TO SEE HER NOW."
WE ARRIVED AT THIS STUDIO
CALLED POODLE PARLOR.
WE WALK STRAIGHT INTO,
I GUESS, A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE EVA'S SHOOTING.
A LITTLE SMIRK.
A LITTLE BIT HAPPY.
I HAVE ADMIRED EVA
SINCE THE SEASON THAT SHE'S WON.
HI, GUYS.
THIS IS SAMARA AND I'M MARIE
FROM "ELLE GIRL" MAGAZINE.
WE'RE DOING A FASHION SHOOT
RIGHT NOW WITH EVA.
IT'S KIND OF BOHEMIAN CHIC
WITH SOME DKNY JEANS PIECES.
BRING YOUR CHIN UP
JUST A LITTLE BIT.
JUST LIKE THAT.
OH MY GOD,
SHE'S SO CUTE.
YOU JUST WANT TO KISS HER.
DITTO.
DELIVER US FROM EVA.
EVA IS THE MOST SUCCESSFUL
WINNER
OF "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
SO WE ALL WANT TO WATCH HER.
HELLO, PRETTY LADIES.
HI.
OH, WOW, I WAS STANDING
RIGHT THERE ONE DAY.
I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE FEELING.
YOU'RE HERE AT WORK WITH ME
TODAY AND YOU GET TO SEE
WHAT THE LIFE OF A WINNER
OF "TOP MODEL" REALLY DOES.
WHEN YOU WORK, YOU'LL HAVE
A NEW ENTOURAGE ALL THE TIME.
SO LEARNING HOW TO GET ALONG
WITH PEOPLE IS SOMETHING
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT.
THIS IS MY ENTOURAGE HERE,
AND THEY ARE WITH ME
ALL THE TIME.
THIS IS MY COUSIN.
HE'S BEEN DOING HAIR AND MAKEUP
FOR OVER TEN YEARS NOW.
THIS IS JONATHAN.
HE'S DOING
MY HAIR TODAY.
IT'S THIS FABULOUS WIG.
AND PHOTOGRAPHER KAREEM.
YOU GUYS MIGHT WANT TO GET
A REALLY GOOD MANAGER, TOO,
YOU HAVE TO LEARN
THAT YOU ARE A COMMODITY NOW
YOU ARE A BRAND.
YOU NEED TO FIND OUT
WHO THE BEST MANAGERS ARE.
TO ME, IT, LIKE, DRIVES ME
A LITTLE BIT TO, LIKE,
THINK ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
THIS COULD BE ME
AND, LIKE, THIS COULD BE
WHAT I COULD BE DOING.
BECAUSE EVA'S AN INSPIRATION.
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW WHAT'S
THE COOLEST THING YOU'VE DONE
SINCE "TOP MODEL"?
TRAVELING IS AMAZING.
AND THE PEOPLE YOU MEET.
NOTHING BUT A RIDE, I CAN SAY.
TO MY TWO SISTERS IN THE CORNER,
I SMELL YOU GUYS HAVE QUESTIONS.
IT IS A LOT HARDER
THAN IT LOOKS.
IT DEFINITELY IS.
YOU GO INTO JUDGING.
LIKE I TOLD TYRA, I'M LIKE,
"I GOT 20 YEARS OF ME,
I COME IN HERE
AND YOU STRIP ME DOWN."
I DEFINITELY GET IT.
THE WORLD STANDARDS OF BEAUTY
ARE WHAT THEY ARE LOOKING AT.
BUT IN THIS COMPETITION,
YOU HAVE TO MAKE
YOUR OWN STANDARD.
USE YOUR WINDOW OF OPPORTUNITY
AND PARLAY THAT INTO WHAT
YOU WANT TO DO.
YOU'RE IN CONTROL
OF YOUR DESTINY!
THAT'S ENOUGH OF MY SERMON.
THANK YOU FOR STOPPING BY.
I'LL SEE YOU LATER.
IT'S COOL, GUYS!
THERE'S WEEKS THAT GO BY
WHERE I'M LIKE, "YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M SICK OF ALL OF THE DRAMA
WITH THE GIRLS."
BUT TALKING TO EVA,
SHE MADE -- REALLY, REALLY MADE
IT SEEM WORTH WHILE
TO WIN THIS COMPETITION.
I WANTED TO SAY,
WHERE DID LISA GO?
PUTTING ON A SHOW.
WHAT SHE DOES BEST.
HOW LONG HAVE YOU GUYS
BEEN HERE TODAY?
SINCE 8:00,
TWO MORE SHOTS TO GO.
OH, NICE.
YOU GOT TO HUSTLE
IN THIS BUSINESS
YOU GOTTA WORK FAST.
YOU GOTTA NETWORK.
♪♪♪
I WOULD LOVE TO BE
LIKE ALL THE OTHER GIRLS
AND JUST SIT AROUND
AND BE BORING.
BUT THE TRUTH IS,
TIME'S A-WASTING.
THIS WHOLE FANTASY
IS GONNA END PRETTY SOON.
I THINK WE HAVE
A GOOD GROUP LEFT.
I LIKE OUR GROUP, YEAH.
ME, TOO.
NO, WE DON'T LIKE YOU, LISA.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT A LOT
OF GIRLS ARE HATING ME
AT THIS POINT.
I MEAN, I THINK
THAT I'M GONNA BE FRIENDLESS.
HELLO?
HELLO.
SO WE GET HOME,
AND THE AIR IN THE HOUSE
IS JUST A LITTLE TOO INTENSE.
AND SO I STARTED DRESSING UP
WITH THESE CRAZY COSTUMES.
I THOUGHT THAT EVERYONE
WAS GONNA LOOSEN UP.
TO BE HONEST, WE'RE ALL
A LITTLE SCARED OF LISA.
WHY DON'T YOU WANT
TO TALK TO ME?
YOU'RE CRAZY, DUDE.
EVERYBODY BE LOOKING AT ME
LIKE I'M CRAZY.
WHY WOULD YOU GET
THE NAPPIEST WIG?
WHY NOT?
EVERYBODY IS TAKING THEMSELVES
WAY TOO SERIOUS.
PSYCHO.
WHAT?
EVERYBODY JUST NEEDS
TO CALM DOWN.
CALM DOWN.
TAKE A BREAK.
EAT A COOKIE.
WE ALL AGREE
THAT LISA IS CRAZY
AND HAS LOST HER DAMN MIND.
HEY, YOU GUYS,
WE HAVE TYRA MAIL.
HAVE YOU EVER FANTASIZED ABOUT
BEING THE HEAD BITCH IN CHARGE?
BE READY AT 1:30 P.M.
I GUESS I HAVE.
WE DRIVE UP DOWNTOWN
LOS ANGELES
IN THE FASHION DISTRICT.
AND WE ARRIVE
AT ANOTHER STUDIO.
WHEN WE WALK THROUGH
THE DOORS,
THERE'S CLOTHES EVERYWHERE...
MAKEUP EVERYWHERE
AND THEN JUST TONS OF PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHAT TO THINK YET.
GIRLS, I'M COVER GIRL
MAKEUP PRO BJ GILLIAN.
YESTERDAY YOU LEARNED
HOW TOP MODELS WORK
WITH AN ENTOURAGE.
TODAY YOU'RE GONNA
GET TO PICK YOUR OWN ENTOURAGE.
EACH OF YOU WILL BE DIRECTING
YOUR OWN HAIR,
MAKEUP AND WARDROBE TEAM.
YOU'RE ALSO GONNA GET TO DESIGN
A COLLAGE THAT REALLY DESCRIBES
WHAT IS UNIQUE ABOUT YOU.
AT THE END OF ALL THIS, YOU'RE
GONNA GET TO PRESENT THIS
IN A GO-SEE FOR A VERY BIG
MANAGER.
I AM THINKING,
"WOW, THIS IS A BIG DEAL."
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY ON A GO-SEE
BUT WHERE IT IS COMING FROM.
COVER GIRL HAS A WIDE VARIETY
OF PRODUCTS FOR LIP COLOR
TO MAKE THE MOST
OF YOUR WINNING SMILE.
YOU'VE ONLY GOT ONE HOUR.
AND THAT STARTS NOW.
I'M GLORIA, MAKEUP AND HAIR.
I WANT TO
LOOK AS CUTE AS YOU.
BASICALLY, WE'RE GONNA PICK OUR
OWN ENTOURAGE
WHICH CONSISTS
OF A PERSONAL ASSISTANT
TO MAKE A POSTER.
MAKEUP/HAIR PERSON,
WARDROBE STYLIST.
IT IS INSANITY.
IT'S CRAZY!
I HATE SO MANY CHOICES.
I AM NOT TOTALLY
LOVING THESE SHOES.
FOR MAKEUP YOU WANT IT
REALLY NATURAL.
I WANT SOMETHING
REALLY SHIMMERY.
WETSLICKS CRYSTALS.
HOW YOU LIKE THIS?
I LIKE THIS.
I LIKE MY ENTOURAGE.
I LIKE THE PEOPLE I PICKED.
I HOPE THEY DIDN'T THINK
THAT I WAS TOO BOSSY.
TEAR IT UNEVEN,
NOT-SO-NEAT LOOK.
A REGULAR, CASUAL T-SHIRT,
UNBUTTON IT ABOUT HALFWAY DOWN
JUST TO SHOW A LITTLE BIT.
RIGHT.
IT SEEMS MY ENTOURAGE WAS MORE
HELPFUL TO ME
THAN IT WAS
TO OTHER GIRLS.
WHICH ONE
DO YOU THINK OF FIRST?
NEITHER.
NEITHER?
WHEN YOU DON'T SEE EYE TO EYE
YOU HAVE TO LET THEM KNOW.
DO I HAVE TO WEAR
YOUR GUYS' CLOTHES
OR CAN I WEAR MY OWN?
ALL OF THESE GREATEST DESIGNERS
HAVE LENT THIS STUFF OUT
FOR YOU GUYS
TO GO ON YOUR GO-SEES.
SO I WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT.
I WOULD TAKE ADVANTAGE OF IT,
TOO, BUT IF I FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE IN MY OWN
CLOTHES, I'D PREFER IT.
YOU NEED TO KIND OF MEET
IN THE MIDDLE SOMEWHERE.
WE DON'T HAVE THE CAMI,
THAT'S TOTALLY FINE.
I WAS THINKING SOMETHING MATTE,
BUT SOMETHING TO MAKE THEM,
LIKE, POUTY.
I HAVE SOMETHING FOR YOU.
IT'S COVER GIRL OUTLAST
SMOOTHWEAR, IT'S GONNA GIVE YOU
UP TO EIGHT HOURS OF WEAR.
WHAT'S AMAZING ABOUT
IT IS
IT HAS THE SAME FINISH
AS A SOFT LIP TINT.
WANT TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR SO
YOU CAN SEE WHAT YOU LOOK LIKE?
NO.
I THINK
THIS SEEMS MORE ME.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
NICOLE, LET'S GO
FOR A SUBTLE LIPSTICK,
LIKE CONTINUOUS COLOR THAT'LL
MAKE THE MOST OF YOUR LIP
WITHOUT MAKING
IT LOOK TOO MUCH, OKAY?
LET'S SEE HOW THIS LOOKS ON YOU.
THAT'S TOTALLY GONNA
MAKE HER LIPS POP.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AFTER WORKING
WITH THE ENTOURAGE,
I UNDERSTAND THAT HAVING ONE
IS VERY IMPORTANT,
BECAUSE THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE GONNA MAKE YOU
LOOK GOOD.
GIRLS, PLEASE GRAB
YOUR COLLAGE AND EXIT.
YOUR TIME IS UP.
HI, LADIES.
WELCOME TO
HANDPRINT ENTERTAINMENT.
I AM JEAN KWOLEK.
I WORK REALLY CLOSELY
WITH BENNY MEDINA.
HE'S ONE OF THE TOP MANAGERS
IN THE ENTERTAINMENT BUSINESS.
BENNY MEDINA, HE'S HUGE.
HE'S REPRESENTED TYRA BANKS,
EVEN MARIAH CAREY.
AND THAT'S JUST CRAZY.
TODAY, WE WILL MEET
WITH YOU INDIVIDUALLY.
SO THE ONE OF YOU WHO
DEMONSTRATES THE MOST
STAR POWER IS GOING TO LAND
A GUEST STARRING ROLE
ON THIS WEEK'S EPISODE
OF "VERONICA MARS."
THIS CHALLENGE
MEANS A LOT TO ME.
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY HARD
TO ACTUALLY LAND A ROLE.
YOU CAN BE THE MOST TALENTED
PERSON IN LOS ANGELES
AND YOU WON'T GET THAT.
HELLO.
HOW ARE YOU?
AMAZING.
HOW ABOUT YOU?
I'M PRETTY GOOD.
MY NAME IS NIK.
YOU KNOW WHY
YOU'RE HERE TODAY?
YES.
HE INTERRUPTS ME
WITH A STERN LOOK IN HIS EYES.
SO IT IS SCARY, BECAUSE IF YOU
DON'T IMPRESS HIM -- WHOO!
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BE CAST IN "VERONICA MARS"
SHOULD YOU WORK THIS OUT.
GO AHEAD.
OKAY.
AS I WOMAN, YOU GO THROUGH
DIFFERENT CHANGES IN LIFE.
AND I ALSO --
OKAY, I'M SORRY.
NOW I'M CAUGHT OFF GUARD
A LITTLE BIT
YOU NOW HAVE 30 SECONDS
TO CONVINCE ME THAT YOU
SHOULD BE THE GUEST STAR
ON "VERONICA MARS."
OKAY.
I THINK I SHOULD BE
THE GUEST STAR
ON "VERONICA MARS"
BECAUSE I'M A VERY POSITIVE
AND RESPONSIBLE YOUNG WOMAN.
AND I JUST THINK THAT WOULD BE
A GREAT THING.
CAN YOU ACT?
HMM?
IF I CAN'T ACT,
I WILL SURE TRY.
DUH, WHY DIDN'T IT CLICK IN MY
MIND THAT I'M SUPPOSED TO BE
TELLING HIM, "YOU SHOULD PICK ME
'CAUSE I AM THE BEST ACTRESS
IN THE WORLD"?
BUT I DIDN'T DO THAT.
OKAY, WELL, IT WAS A PLEASURE
MEETING YOU.
NICE TO MEET YOU.
NIK WAS JUST REALLY BEAUTIFUL
BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO LISTEN
TO WHAT SHE HAD TO SAY.
TELL ME WHAT YOU GOT.
THIS IS MY BEST FRIEND
FROM HOME, MY BOYFRIEND
AND MY FAMILY AND I ALSO HAVE MY
QUOTE ON THERE --
"BE HAPPY FOR THIS MOMENT"--
WHAT ON THERE SHOWS ME
THAT YOU HAVE
ANY TRUE ARTISTIC INCLINATION?
YOU GOT 30 SECONDS TO TELL ME
WHY YOU THINK YOU'LL BE A STAR.
I THINK I WILL BE A STAR,
'CAUSE THERE'S, LIKE,
TWO DIFFERENT SIDES TO ME.
THERE'S A CRAZY, WILD SIDE
WHO LOVES TO HAVE FUN,
BUT THERE'S ALSO THE OTHER.
WHAT ABOUT TALENT?
I HAVE LOTS OF TALENT.
OKAY.
YOU SHOULD HAVE
SAID THAT FIRST.
THANKS A LOT.
MY PAPER IS ALL SCRUNCHED UP
TO DESCRIBE THE STRUGGLE
THAT I WENT THROUGH
IN EVERY DIFFERENT STAGE
OF MY LIFE GROWING UP.
GIVE ME A MOMENT.
I'M, LIKE, MESSING UP.
WHY DID YOU FEEL
YOU WERE MESSING UP?
I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
THIS IS JUST YOUR LIFE
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT IF I PUT A SCRIPT
IN FRONT OF YOU?
IT WOULD BE QUICK FOR ME
TO GO INTO ROLE PLAY.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
SEXY SISTER -- BRE --
SHE'S A VERY, VERY HUNGRY GIRL
AND A VERY PASSIONATE GIRL.
HELLO.
I GUESS MY STRATEGY
FOR MARKETING MYSELF
IS MAKING SURE THAT I'M AS LOUD
AND ENERGETIC AS POSSIBLE.
I WANT TO KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO.
ALL RIGHT.
AS I CHILD, YOU KNOW, A LOT OF
THINGS -- YOU'RE PUSHED ALONG.
YOU DON'T REALLY HAVE CONTROL
OVER YOURSELF.
STARTING TO GET TO MY GROWN
STAGE, LEARNING TO MOVE AROUND.
LAX PERIOD -- WENT THROUGH
SOME DARK STAGES AS A KID,
AND THEN AT THE TOP,
WE HAVE MY LITTLE SISTER.
SHE'S CLOSE TO THE TOP,
BECAUSE SHE'S THE SPITTING IMAGE
OF ME, AND I FEEL I HAVE TO SHOW
WHERE I AM AT NOW
HOW I WANT TO BE A MODEL.
I WOULD GIVE YOU MY 100% BEST
THAT I CAN EVER GIVE ANYONE.
THANK YOU.
HONESTLY, I STILL CAN'T
REMEMBER JAYLA.
JUST SOMEHOW STILL DIDN'T HAVE
ANY PERSONAL RESONANCE,
AND I WAS LOOKING TO CAST TODAY.
I-- BESIDES BEING VERSATILE,
I HAVE ACTED BEFORE.
I HAVE DONE
A LITTLE BIT OF MODELING.
AND I THINK A LOT OF THE REASON
WHY I HAVE DONE WELL
IN THE COMPETITION IS THE FACT
THAT I DO
DIVERSIFY THE COMPETITION.
BUT RIGHT NOW MY PASSION
IS SO CLEARLY MODELING.
MY PASSION HAS BEEN ACTING
BEFORE WHEN I DID IT IN SCHOOL.
THANK YOU.
I JUST FELT LIKE KIM HAD
ENOUGH ANGST AND ENOUGH PASSION.
THERE WAS SOMETHING ABOUT JUST
HER PEDIGREE I THOUGHT ALSO
THAT BODE WELL FOR HER.
TELL ME WHY YOU CAN BE A STAR
IN 30 SECONDS.
I HAVE BEEN THROUGH
SO MUCH IN MY LIFE.
EVERYTHING THAT COULD POSSIBLY
BE THROWN AT ME
HAS BEEN THROWN AT ME.
PUT IT ANYTHING IN FRONT OF ME
I CAN HANDLE MYSELF.
I WILL DO IT BEAUTIFULLY AS WELL
AND I WILL
SMILE AT THE VERY END.
WHY ARE YOU NEAR TEARS?
I HAVE BEEN WAITING FOR AN
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY LIKE THIS
MY WHOLE LIFE AND YOU TWO
ARE IN FRONT OF ME RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
WHY DO YOU THINK
SHE STARTED TO CRY?
IT WAS WEIRD.
I THINK THAT SHE WAS OVERWHELMED
BY THE SITUATION.
INTERESTING.
SO TONIGHT,
BENNY AND I HAVE DELIBERATED.
AND THE GIRL THAT WE THINK
HAS THE MOST STAR POTENTIAL
IS KIM.
SO YOU CAN COME UP HERE.
YOU HAVE LANDED A GUEST ROLE
ON UPN'S HIT SERIES
"VERONICA MARS."
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
I DEFINITELY WANT TO BE
ON AN EPISODE
OF "VERONICA MARS."
I'M EXCITED.
I THINK IT'LL BE REALLY FUN.
WHOA.
THIS WEEK IS THE FIRST WEEK
WHERE I'M THINKING TO MYSELF,
"MAYBE I CAN WIN THIS THING."
YEAH, IT STINGS A LITTLE BIT
THAT KIM WON AND I DIDN'T.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THAT'S OKAY.
HEY.
HOW'S IT GOING?
I'M HERE ON THE SET
OF "VERONICA MARS,"
AND I AM EXCITED ABOUT IT.
ACTING IS NERVE-RACKING.
I'VE NEVER REALLY
DONE IT BEFORE.
IT WILL BE A CHALLENGE,
BUT MY CHARACTER IS SORT OF
A JADED UNDERACHIEVER,
SHE'S VERY SARCASTIC.
I MEAN, I CAN DO THAT.
KRISTEN BELL IS SO NICE.
SHE GAVE ME
SOME POSITIVE FEEDBACK.
LET ME KNOW
IF YOU WANT TO REHEARSE.
YEAH.
YOU CAN TOTALLY REHEARSE.
YEAH, THAT'D BE GOOD.
ACTION.
YOU HAVE TO HELP ME.
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM?
I LEFT MY LAPTOP
IN THE RENTAL,
AND NOW I'M TOTALLY SCREWED!
BUMMER.
REMEMBER THE CAR?
A WHITE LE SABRE,
AND IT WAS TURNED IN LAST WEEK.
DIAL THE PHONE, KIM.
CUT!
35.
TAKE TWO.
HI, I AM CALLING FROM SAN DIEGO.
I'M TRYING TO
LOCATE A CAR.
CODE IS 92347.
IN A PARKING GARAGE
OR SOMETHING.
AT FIRST, HAVING THE CAMERAS
ALL IN MY FACE WAS CONFUSING.
BUT AT SOME POINT YOU JUST
LOOK AT THE OTHER PERSON
YOU'RE ACTING WITH IN THE SCENE,
AND YOU IGNORE THE REST
OF WHAT'S GOING ON AROUND YOU.
SO TWO DAYS AGO
THEY WERE RIGHT HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
PLEASE CALL IF YOU HEAR
ANYTHING ELSE.
I HOPE YOUR BOSS GETS CANNED.
YOURS TOO.
CUT!
TODAY WAS A REALLY EXCITING DAY
FOR ME.
I TOTALLY DID SOMETHING
I'VE NEVER DONE BEFORE,
AND I REALLY LIKED IT.
THAT'S A WRAP!
OKAY, GUYS, KIM, THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
I AM EXCITED.
I CAN'T
BELIEVE I WON THAT.
EVERYONE ELSE HAS WON.
I BETTER WIN SOMETHING.
I WANTED TO WIN.
BUT IF I DIDN'T,
IT'S ALL GOOD.
I WON TWO CHALLENGES,
LIKE, I'M HAPPY.
YEAH, DUDE.
CONGRATULATIONS, KIM.
IT'S ABOUT TIME
I WON SOMETHING.
YOU DESERVED TO WIN ONE.
LISA, SHE WAS BEING PASSIVE
AGGRESSIVE.
SHE'S LIKE, "KIM, I AM HAPPY,
'CAUSE YOU DESERVE
TO WIN ONE CHALLENGE."
WHEN YOUR NAME WAS CALLED,
I WAS PROUD OF YOU.
GOOD JOB.
YOU MUST HAVE SAID THINGS
THAT I DIDN'T SAY.
GOOD FOR YOU.
AM I JEALOUS?
NO.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
CONGRATULATIONS, KIM.
EVERYONE CAN SEE THROUGH
THAT, YOU JEALOUS IDIOT.
OH, MY GOODNESS.
TYRA MAIL.
OKAY.
"DON'T LET YOUR FEARS
OF THE WILD KEEP YOU
FROM LOOKING FIERCE, TYRA."
WILD ANIMALS.
ARE WE GOING TO BE ANIMALS?
PROBABLY.
WE DRIVE UP
TO THIS BEAUTIFUL HOUSE
IN THE HOLLYWOOD HILLS.
WE ARE LIKE, "OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO DO A SHOOT
WITH SOME ANIMALS."
I DON'T KNOW, YOU KNOW?
COME ON IN.
TODAY, WE'RE GONNA DO
WHAT WE CALL HIGH FASHION MAD,
LIKE, WHEN MODELS GO CRAZY
AND THEY'RE LIKE, "RAH!"
YOU GET TO CUT LOOSE.
YOU GET TO HAVE FUN.
I AM THINKING, "SWEET!"
SWEET.
SO NADIA YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
IS EXCELLENT
AT CAPTURING SCENES.
NADIA COME ON OUT HERE.
THERE THEY ARE.
HI, GIRLS.
HI.
I WANT YOU GUYS TO GO DOWN TO
HAIR AND MAKEUP,
AND THEN I'M GONNA
BRING YOU UP
AS WE GO THROUGH
OUR LITTLE SCENARIOS.
ALL RIGHT?
WA, WA.
ALL OF THE GIRLS, WE'RE ALL
GETTING OUR MAKEUP DONE
AND JAY GETS US AND TELLS US
TO COME BACK UPSTAIRS.
I WANT YOU GIRLS
TO BE ANGRY IN YOUR SHOTS.
I NEED A LITTLE SOMETHING
TO ANTAGONIZE YOU.
CLEARLY I AM NOT ENOUGH.
DO YOU GUYS KNOW WHO THESE
GUYS ARE?
HI, LADIES.
MTV WILDBOYZ.
I KNOW THESE GUYS
USED TO BE ON "JACKASS."
AND I'VE ALWAYS BEEN, LIKE,
A HUGE FAN OF IT.
I MEAN, YOU THINK LISA'S BAD,
THESE GUYS ARE RIDICULOUS.
THESE GUYS ARE THE GUYS YOU'RE
ACTUALLY WORKING WITH
IN YOUR SHOTS TODAY.
ALL WEEK YOU'VE BEEN LEARNING
ABOUT ENTOURAGES
AND THE WILDBOYZ ARE GOING TO BE
YOUR ENTOURAGE GONE WILD.
HELL YEAH.
SWEET.
COME ON, BRE.
I'M SCARED.
I DON'T REALLY WANT
TO WORK WITH THEM.
ALL YOU NEED IS THE WEE.
YOU LOOK LIKE YOU
GONNA BE A PROBLEM.
A PROBLEM?
I'M GONNA BE THE ANSWER.
WHERE YOU GOING, SWEETHEART?
I WILL SEE YOU LATER, HONEY.
I GOT TO GO GET READY.
YOU'RE READY ENOUGH FOR US.
THE PERSON
WHO WOULD MOST LIKELY
GET ALONG WITH THE WILDBOYZ
IS DISGUSTING, CRAZY -- LISA.
ARE WE READY TO GO ON THIS?
TO BRING THE WILDBOYZ IN,
IT WAS LIKE,
"SEE, I'M NOT THE ONLY ONE
THAT'S CRAZY."
LISA, I WANT TO HEAR YOU YELL.
YOU'RE GETTING
READY TO GO OUT.
BUT THESE GUYS HAVE HOLD
OF YOUR MAKEUP KIT.
COME.
DAMN IT, YOU GUYS,
I SWEAR I WANT YOU
TO GET OUT OF HERE ALREADY.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING
WITH MY MAKEUP FOR?
OH!
I'M SERIOUS.
WHOA.
LISA,
DON'T DO SO MUCH OF THIS --
AND YELLING.
YOU GUYS, READY?
TURN MORE
TOWARDS CAMERA, LISA.
SERIOUSLY.
YOU'RE MAD, LISA.
PRO ABOUT LISA,
SHE WAS THE FIRST ONE UP
AND JUST KILLED IT.
OW!
YEAH.
YOU'RE ABOUT TO TEAR
THOSE BOYS A NEW ONE.
YOU ARE MAD AT THEM,
TICKED OFF.
THEY'VE GOT YOUR UNDERWEAR
AND YOU'RE IN YOUR TOWEL
AND YOU NEED TO BE
IN YOUR UNDERWEAR.
SO YOU ARE MAD.
I NEED TO
HEAR YOU SCREAM.
SCREAM, BRE.
READY, GO.
AH!
YOU ARE TRYING TO GET
TO AN EVENT.
YEAH!
AH!
STEVE-O IS THROWING PANTIES
IN MY FACE --
AH!
AND NOW I'M REALLY PISSED OFF.
WHEN THE PANTIES
WERE BEING THROWN AT HER,
A LOT OF CHICKS DON'T LIKE THAT.
ONE, TWO, THREE.
AH!
WE GOT THE SHOT.
WE'RE DONE,
IT'S A WRAP.
GOOD SPORTS.
SOMEBODY'S
BEEN WEARING THESE THESE.
I WANT TO KNOW
WHO THEIR PARENTS ARE,
BECAUSE I WAS NOT AMUSED BY
THEIR LITTLE CHILDISH GAMES,
NOT AT ALL.
YOU'RE PISSED OFF.
YOU JUST CAUGHT THEM
IN BED TOGETHER.
START SCENE.
I KNEW IT WOULD BE FUNNY
'CAUSE SHE'S GAY.
WE'RE ALL LIKE, "OH, LET'S TURN
THE LESBIAN STRAIGHT."
ONE, TWO, THREE, SCREAM.
WHAT'S GOING ON?!
MY BOYFRIEND
IS CHEATING ON ME!
OH, MY GOD!
YOU'RE MAD, NOT HAPPY.
WHAT IS GOING ON?!
YOU ARE CHEATING ON ME.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU'RE
CONVERTING A LESBIAN.
I KEPT LAUGHING
THROUGHOUT MY WHOLE THING,
'CAUSE THEY WERE SO FUNNY.
MOAN, ACT LIKE YOU LIKE IT!
(SCREAMING)
I FELT NICOLE
WAS A LITTLE BIT FAKE.
WHAT IS GOING ON?!
OH, MY GOD.
WHAT?!
MY LOVER'S
CHEATING ON ME.
KEEP IT GOING.
KEEP IT,
KEEP IT, KEEP IT.
KEEP IT GOING.
NICOLE WAS THE BEST.
JUST SMACKING ME WITH THE PURSE,
I LOVED IT.
LOOK, THERE IS YOUR BOYFRIEND.
I THINK THAT I DID
A REALLY GOOD JOB TODAY.
I HAD FUN AND I THINK
IT SHOWED.
JAYLA.
YOU CAN'T REALLY SCREAM
BECAUSE WE MIGHT FRIGHTEN
THE DOG.
OKAY.
JAYLA WAS CONFIDENT.
SHE KIND OF HAD ONE LOOK,
THOUGH.
SCREAM.
MORE ENERGY, JAYLA.
JAYLA HAD A BIG CHALLENGE
ON HER HANDS.
WHEN YOU ARE WORKING
WITH WILD ANIMALS...
NOTHING IS REALLY COMPLETELY
IN YOUR CONTROL.
I DIDN'T GET TO SEE
HER PERFORMANCE BECAUSE I WAS
MAKING OUT WITH THE DOG.
IT WAS WEIRD SCREAMING
BUT NOT REALLY SCREAMING,
BUT I THINK I LANDED
AT LEAST ONE GOOD SHOT.
COME ON, NIK.
THEY HAVE YOUR DRESSES ON,
AND YOU GOTTA START SCREAMING.
READY?
ONE, TWO, THREE.
(SCREAMING)
OKAY, AGAIN.
ONE, TWO, THREE.
(SCREAMING)
OKAY, AGAIN.
I KEPT SEEING EVERYONE LAUGH.
I KNEW THEY WEREN'T
LAUGHING AT ME.
'CAUSE WHATEVER I WAS DOING
WAS NOT THAT FUNNY.
(SCREAMING)
OKAY, AGAIN,
ONE, TWO, THREE.
(SCREAMING)
IS THAT IT?
YEAH, WE GOT IT.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S GET SET UP
OUTSIDE, EVERYBODY.
WHAT HAPPENED BEHIND ME?
PENIS, A WHOLE LOT OF IT.
THERE WAS A WHOLE LOT OF THIS
WITH THE DRESSES.
I HAD NO IDEA.
I REALLY DON'T KNOW HOW I DID
ON THIS PHOTO SHOOT.
I HOPE I GOT A GOOD SHOT
BECAUSE I REALLY DON'T
WANT TO GO HOME.
KIM, I DON'T
WANT YOU TO ANALYZE IT.
I WANT YOU TO GET INTO IT
AND JUST FEEL THE MOOD.
ONE, TWO, THREE, GO.
(SCREAMING)
AGAIN.
WHEN YOU'RE TIRED OF SCREAMING,
PAUSE AND THEN SCREAM AGAIN.
ARE WE READY?
ONE, TWO, THREE.
(SCREAMING)
OKAY, AGAIN.
I ALMOST PASSED OUT FOUR TIMES
BECAUSE I SCREAMED FOR SO LONG.
(SCREAMING)
WE GOT IT, THAT'S IT.
THE BEST THING ABOUT KIM
IS HER ATTITUDE.
NOT WITH THAT OUTFIT,
THAT OUTFIT.
NO!
THAT'S WHAT I SAID, GUYS.
I DID MY BEST TO CONVERT HER
FROM HER LESBIANISM.
CAN I HAVE A TOWEL.
WHICH YOU PROBABLY DID.
YEAH, BUT I DON'T THINK SHE WAS
100% LESBIAN TO BEGIN WITH.
YEAH, NOBODY IS.
SO YOU'RE
MOVING TO HOLLYWOOD?
I DON'T KNOW YET.
YOU CAN STAY WITH ME
WHILE YOU'RE LOOKING FOR A PAD.
NICOLE GETS ALONG BEST
WITH THE WILDBOYZ.
STEVE-O IS IN LOVE WITH HER.
HE'S RUBBING HER FEET,
AND SHE'S ENJOYING
ALL THE MALE ATTENTION.
YOU'RE IN LOVE?
YEAH, AND THESE FINGERS
ARE ON LOAN FROM GOD.
I'M WEARING YOUR GUYS'
UNDERWEAR.
WHY?
WHY NOT?
WHEN I WAS GETTING A LITTLE
BIT OF ATTENTION FROM STEVE-O.
LISA WALKS IN WITH A DIAPER ON,
SHE HAS TO OUTSHINE EVERYONE.
SHE IS SO WEIRD.
SHE'S SO "FATAL ATTRACTION."
WHY IS SHE WEARING A DIAPER
AGAIN?
I DON'T KNOW.
I JUST THOUGHT I WOULD ASK.
LISA, DON'T PEE IN THAT.
NO, PLEASE DO.
LISA, PLEASE.
THEN LISA ANNOUNCES THAT SHE IS
GOING TO PEE IN THE DIAPER.
(LAUGHING)
OH, NO!
OH, MY GOD.
SHE'S DOING IT, DUDE!
YOU CAN TOTALLY SEE HER!
NO WOMAN OF CLASS, ESPECIALLY
A SUPERMODEL IN THE MAKING,
IS GONNA DO SOMETHING AS
DISGUSTING AS PEE ON HERSELF
AT HER JOB.
I FEEL DISGUSTED.
I AM EMBARRASSED
AS A COMPETITOR TO BE SEEN
WITH THIS TYPE OF PERSON.
I AM AFRAID THAT LISA'S
RUINING HER CHANCES OF WINNING.
CAN I PLEASE SIT
BY A NORMAL PERSON?
SURE.
OKAY, OKAY.
LISA, SHE'S A SICK INDIVIDUAL,
AND IF SHE WINS THIS
COMPETITION,
I HOPE USES THE $100,000
AND CHECKS HERSELF
INTO A PSYCHE WORD ASAP.
TYRA MAIL.
BRE, LISA, EVERYONE, HONEY.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
ONLY FIVE WILL CONTINUE ON
WITH THE HOPE OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED."
I STARTED OFF THIS THING
THINKING I HAD NO CHANCE,
BUT NOW I DEFINITELY HAVE
A CHANCE OF WINNING,
AND I AM GONNA TRY SO HARD.
I BELIEVE IN MYSELF NOW.
YOU ALREADY KNOW
THAT IF I GET ELIMINATED
MY LIFE WILL END.
I'M ALWAYS NERVOUS
FOR EVERY ELIMINATION WE GO TO.
THEY SHOCK YOU EVERY TIME.
NOW IT IS TIME TO MAKE OUR
7TH CUT, WHICH WILL BRING US
ONE STEP CLOSER
TOWARDS DETERMINING WHO WILL
BECOME AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
AND YOU GUYS KNOW ABOUT
THESE PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH TOP MODEL MANAGEMENT
COMPANY FORD MODELS.
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
SHOT BY WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER, THAT PRETTY MUCH
PUT ME ON THE MAP,
MR. GILES BENSIMONE,
AND A COVER OF "ELLE GIRL"
MAGAZINE AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVER GIRL COSMETICS.
AND OF COURSE YOU KNOW
ABOUT THESE JUDGES.
FIRST, MR. NIGEL BARKER,
NOTED FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
HI, LADIES.
HI.
MISS J. ALEXANDER, OUR FIERCE,
FABULOUS RUNWAY COACH,
AND MISS '60s LEGENDARY ICON
FASHION STAR HERSELF
MISS TWIGGY.
HELLO.
AND THE PHOTOGRAPHER THAT SHOT
YOUR CRAZY PICTURES THIS WEEK.
NADIA PANDOLFO.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS.
AFTER THAT, THE JUDGES WILL
DELIBERATE, AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
SO THIS WEEK YOU LEARNED ABOUT
ENTOURAGES AND STAR POWER
AND BEING
A STAR IS ABOUT BEING VERSATILE,
ESPECIALLY WITH BEING A MODEL.
IT'S ABOUT BEING COMMERCIAL,
IT'S ABOUT BEING EDGY,
IT'S ABOUT
ENDORSING PRODUCTS.
SO THAT'S WHAT YOUR EVALUATION
IS GOING TO BE BASED ON TODAY.
JAYLA, YOU ARE FIRST.
MISS JAYLA, IF YOU LOOK
TO YOUR LEFT THERE ARE
THREE PRODUCTS UNDERNEATH
THOSE SILVER PLATES.
THE FIRST ONE
IS A COMMERCIAL PRODUCT.
GIVE US POSES IMMEDIATELY
REPRESENTING THAT PRODUCT
AS A COMMERCIAL PRINT MODEL.
DON'T LAUGH AT ME,
NIGEL.
THE NEXT ONE IT
IS A HIGH FASHION EDITORIAL.
OKAY, SORRY,
TOOK ME A SECOND.
OOH.
THOSE ARE MY GLASSES.
BE CAREFUL.
OH, ARE THEY?
I'M SORRY.
MODELS ALSO HAVE TO BE ENDORSERS
FOR TELEVISION AND FOR PRODUCTS.
SEE THAT NICE PIECE
OF CHOCOLATE?
WE WANT YOU TO PITCH THAT
AS IF IT IS A COMMERCIAL.
IT'S ANTM CHOCOLATE.
YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE TO DO SO,
YOU MUST FILL THE MINUTE.
GO.
MODELS AREN'T SUPPOSED
TO EAT CHOCOLATE.
BUT I EAT CHOCOLATE EVERY DAY.
IT'S THE CREAMIEST,
DREAMIEST CHOCOLATE AROUND.
YOU CAN USE IT
IN SO MANY WAYS,
FOR AROUSAL.
IT'S GREAT,
IT'S ANTM.
IT'S CHOCOLATE.
♪ I LOVE MY ANTM CHOCOLATE ♪♪
MM!
CHOCOLATE --
IT'S CHOCOLATE.
IT'S -- IT'S CHOCOLATY.
IT'S ANTM CHOCOLATE.
♪ OOH I DO ♪
OH, GOD.
I'LL GIVE YOU
EACH A PIECE.
SO YOU CAN
TRY IT YOURSELF.
SOMETIMES I COME HOME
LATE AT NIGHT, AND I PICK UP
A NICE PIECE OF ANTM
CHOCOLATE.
I LOVE --
ANTM CHOCOLATE.
THIS IS AWESOME.
I WISH THE MINUTE
CAN GO ON LONGER.
I HATE CHOCOLATE.
(LAUGHING)
JAYLA, CAN STEP FORWARD
FIRST.
ALL RIGHT, JAYLA,
SO WE HAD A TEST
OF HOW VERSATILE CAN YOU BE.
WHO SAID MODELS
SHOULDN'T EAT CHOCOLATE?
EVERYONE.
I DISAGREE.
AND SEE, I AM SEXY CHOCOLATE,
BABY.
THE CHOCOLATE,
I FELT LIKE YOU WERE JUST
AFRAID OF THE PRODUCT.
YOU SEEMED EMBARRASSED
FOR THE CHOCOLATE COMMERCIAL.
YOU DIDN'T GET SEXY EITHER.
YOU SHOULD HAVE SLATHERED
YOURSELF WITH CHOCOLATE.
DON'T BE AFRAID.
THIS WEEK YOU HAD TO SHOOT
WITH THE WILDBOYZ FROM MTV.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
CAN WE SEE IT
CLOSE UP?
IT'S ALMOST LIKE
A BLOW-UP DOLL.
I THINK, IN GENERAL, YOU NEED TO
LEARN
TO USE YOUR BODY MORE.
BECAUSE SEX SELLS.
THAT SHOULD BE ON A BOX --
A BLOW-UP DOLL BOX.
UP NEXT WE HAVE NIK.
ABOUT THE TOOTH PASTE,
I DIDN'T FEEL LIKE YOU CONNECTED
WITH THE PRODUCT AT ALL.
YOUR CHOCOLATE
COMMERCIAL --
CHOCOLATE --
IT'S CHOCOLATE.
IT'S ANTM CHOCOLATE.
YOU FOUND THE MINUTE A BIT LONG
BUT ACTUALLY YOU DID IT
VERY WELL I THOUGHT
UNTIL YOU RAN OUT
OF SOMETHING TO SAY.
ALL RIGHT, NIK,
HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
IT IS QUITE INTENSE.
IT IS, THAT IS A POWERFUL
SCREAM.
AND I CAN HEAR THE AUDIO
FROM LOOKING AT THE PICTURE.
AH!
IN GOING THROUGH YOUR FILM,
YOU DID THE BEST
OUT OF ALL OF THE GIRLS.
YOU HAD TONS OF DIFFERENT TYPES
OF SCREAMS
AND THE FACE
IS STILL PRETTY.
THANK YOU.
UP NEXT WE HAVE KIM.
I THOUGHT IT WAS A NICE STALL
PASSING OUT THE CHOCOLATE.
YEAH.
TEN SECONDS LEFT,
NINE SECONDS LEFT.
YOU GAVE UP.
YOU GAVE UP
AND LAUGHED IT OFF.
AND HERE IS YOUR
BEST SHOT.
THAT IS A GREAT PHOTO.
FOR ME,
THIS IS THE MOST ATTRACTIVE
I'VE EVER SEEN YOU LOOK.
AND I THINK THIS IS ONE OF HER
BEST PICTURES
BECAUSE SHE WAS
WHAT?
ONE OF THE BOYS.
THANK YOU.
YOU FELT LIKE ONE OF THE BOYS,
GIRL, SO YOU FIT RIGHT IN.
THANK YOU.
LISA.
NOW, LISA, I GOT TO TELL YOU
THAT YOUR EDITORIAL,
WHEN YOU LEAPED, FIRST,
I THOUGHT YOU WERE CRAZY.
BUT IF THERE WAS A STILL PHOTO
THAT CAPTURED THAT LEAP,
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN GORGEOUS.
IT REMINDS ME OF A PHOTO
THAT GILES BENSIMONE TOOK OF ME
WHEN I WAS 19.
YOU MOVE WONDERFULLY.
I LOVED YOUR
LEAP ACROSS.
I PANICKED WHEN THEY DROPPED
BECAUSE I KNEW
THEY WERE TYRA'S GLASSES.
THEY ONLY COST $15.
SO LET'S GO TO YOUR PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
OOH, CHILD, HER NECK IS GONE.
YOU'VE GONE FOR THE MOMENT
AND GONE TOO FAR.
LISA, YOU NEED TO LEARN
NOT TO GO ALL THE WAY CRAZY.
LIKE A MONSTER.
ALL RIGHT, UP NEXT IS BRE.
I LOVED YOUR COMMERCIAL.
THERE WAS NOT ONE AWKWARD PAUSE
IN THAT SEXY CHOCOLATE
COMMERCIAL.
I CLOSED MY EYES, BRE,
WHEN YOU WERE TALKING.
THE FUNNY THING IS
WHEN I'M LISTENING TO YOU TALK,
I FEEL THAT YOU ARE PUTTING ON
AN ACT AND TRYING TO SOUND
POSHER THAN YOU ARE.
I WANNA BE MYSELF, BUT I
DON'T WANT TO BE LIKE,
"YEAH, GIRL,
LET ME TELL YOU, 'CAUSE..."
TWIGGY, YOU CAN SPEAK
ABOUT THAT.
I CERTAINLY CAN.
I WAS THE FIRST
WORKING-CLASS MODEL.
MOST MODELS IN ENGLAND
HAD VERY POSH ACCENTS
AND I DIDN'T.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE ASHAMED
AND THINK,
OH, I'VE GOT TO BE THIS
AND GOT TO BE THAT
BECAUSE YOU
LOSE YOUR NATURALNESS.
UP NEXT IS YOUR PHOTO.
BRE, I THINK THIS IS ONE
OF YOUR BETTER PHOTOGRAPHS.
WELL DONE,
THIS IS WHAT WE WANT TO SEE.
WE WANT TO SEE YOU STARTING
TO GET INTO IT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, NICOLE.
WHEN IN DOUBT,
SING AND DANCE.
♪ I LOVE MY ANTM CHOCOLATE ♪
♪ ANTM CHOCOLATE ♪
IT COULD
BECOME A HIT SONG.
IT WAS A NICE WAY TO END,
BECAUSE YOU STARTED WEAK.
YOUR POSES WERE SAFE.
IF YOU CAN'T
TAKE YOURSELF SERIOUSLY,
YOU'RE NEVER GONNA BE ANYTHING
MORE THAN A CATALOG MODEL,
EVEN IF THAT.
SO, NICOLE, YOU HAD
A PHOTO SHOOT
AND HERE IS YOUR BEST SHOT.
SHE CAME INTO THE ROOM AND SHE
CAUGHT HER MAN IN THE BED
WITH KIM.
NO, GIRL, WHEN THAT HAPPENS,
YOU JUMP IN THE MIDDLE.
I TRIED.
I FELT LIKE YOU WERE HOLDING
YOURSELF BACK
AND YOU'RE EMBARRASSED.
YEAH, I THINK IT WAS MORE OF A
FEAR OF EVERYONE WATCHING
THAN, LIKE, MYSELF.
YOU'VE GOT TO BECOME
MORE CONFIDENT.
THANK YOU.
SO NOW IT IS TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I WILL ANNOUNCE WHICH ONE OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
NIK.
(SCREAMING)
WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME
IN THIS PHOTOGRAPH
IS THAT WE'VE GOT THREE MEN
IN WOMEN'S CLOTHING,
BUT MY EYES GO TO HER.
FINALLY WE ARE BEGINNING
TO FEEL
A LITTLE BIT
OF NIK'S PERSONALITY.
A COUPLE OF WEEKS SHE WOULD
HAVE BEEN LIKE, "I AM SCARED."
LISA.
LISA'S GOT SO MUCH
PERSONALITY.
I THINK
THAT'S WHY WE LOVE HER.
I JUST DON'T THINK
SHE HAS A GREAT FACE.
I DON'T THINK SHE COULD GET
TO THE TOP LEVEL.
EVEN WITH THAT PERSONALITY?
NO.
JAYLA.
THIS WEEK JAYLA
IS LOOKING REALLY TIRED.
PERSONALLY, THIS IS THE WORST
I'VE SEEN HER.
I AM CONFUSED
ABOUT JAYLA.
SHE DOESN'T MAKE ANY
IMPRESSIONS.
SHE IS ONE OF THOSE KIND OF
MODELS
WHO THINKS
SHE CAN JUST STAND.
SHE'S BORING.
I ACTUALLY LOVE
THE WAY SHE LOOKS.
BRE.
BRE I THINK HAS
FINALLY TURNED THE GAME UP.
IF SHE CAN JUST GET OVER
THAT THING ABOUT BEING POSH.
SHE IS TRYING TO BE BRIANA
AND JUST NEEDS TO BE LEBRENA.
KIM.
I THINK SHE LOOKS
REALLY GIRLY
IN THIS LITTLE PINK FROCK.
KIM IS FINALLY
TAKING GOOD PICTURES.
IN FACT, THIS IS PROBABLY THE
BEST PICTURE OF THE BUNCH.
NICOLE.
WHEN SHE GOT
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
SHE'S THE MOST
SELF-CONSCIOUS GIRL
AND SHE NEVER GIVES 100%.
THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT NICOLE
IS 50% ACTUALLY PROVIDES YOU
WITH A GOOD PHOTOGRAPH.
THE BAD NEWS IS NICOLE
DOESN'T BELIEVE IN HERSELF.
WELL, I'VE
ALWAYS LOVED NICOLE.
SHE DOES PHOTOGRAPH WELL,
BUT SHE'S GOT TO KIND OF
TO UP THE ANTE I THINK.
WE'VE REACHED A DECISION.
A STRANGE ONE.
A VERY STRANGE ONE.
VERY, VERY STRANGE.
♪♪♪
THIS WAS AN INTERESTING
JUDGING TONIGHT.
AND THERE ARE DEFINITE
FRONTRUNNERS HERE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME,
THE JUDGES ARE FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME OF YOU
THAT WE FEEL
HAVE NOT PROGRESSED
AND THAT SHOULD BE A LOT
FURTHER THAN WHERE THEY
ARE RIGHT NOW.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I AM GOING TO CALL
IS SOMEONE THAT'S PROGRESSING.
BRE.
LOOK AT YOURSELF
IN THIS PICTURE.
THAT'S A MODEL, BRE.
BUT WHAT YOU NEED TO BREAK OUT
OF IS TRYING TO BE PERFECT.
LITTLE GHETTO STREET EDGE --
THAT IS WHAT LITTLE GIRLS
WANT TO LOOK UP TO.
SOMEBODY THAT'S HERSELF,
SOMEBODY THAT IS REAL,
SOMEBODY THAT'S LIKE THEM.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
YOU ARE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I AM GOING TO CALL --
KIM.
NIK.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THE NEXT NAME
I AM GOING TO CALL --
LISA!
AH!
YOU KNOW
WHAT YOUR CRITIQUE IS.
YEAH.
GIVE US STRONG FACES
BUT NOT SO STRONG
THAT THEY
TURN INTO UGLY FACES.
CONGRATULATIONS.
THANK YOU.
OOH, INTENSE.
WILL JAYLA AND NICOLE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
YOU TWO ARE EXQUISITE,
BEAUTIFUL GIRLS.
YOU TAKE BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
BUT TODAY, WHEN YOU BOTH
OPENED YOUR MOUTHS,
WE SAID THERE IS NO WAY
THAT THEY CAN REPRESENT
A PRODUCT.
YOU TWO WERE AT THE TOP
OF THE PACK.
AND NOW YOU STAND BEFORE ME
AT THE BOTTOM.
WITH MODELING,
YOU GUYS HAVE TO BE ON POINT.
YOU HAVE TO BE FIERCE.
YOU HAVE TO BE
READY.
BUT THE JUDGES WERE
SO DISAPPOINT IN YOU,
THAT TONIGHT BOTH OF YOU
MUST PACK YOUR BAGS...
BECAUSE WE'RE ALL GOING
TO LONDON!
AND YOU AND YOU AND YOU
YOU AND YOU AND YOU!
GOING TO LONDON!
NOBODY IS
GOING HOME!
DID I FREAK YOU OUT?!
YES!
MY HEART HAS NEVER BEAT
THIS HARD IN A JUDGING EVER.
NOW THAT I'VE BEEN
ALMOST ELIMINATED --
IT'S OKAY, I WAS JUST
FAKING YOU OUT.
THAT WAS NOT A GOOD FEELING
AT ALL.
I DON'T WANT THAT TO HAPPEN
EVER AGAIN.
AFTER THAT LITTLE SCARE,
IT DEFINITELY
MAKES YOU
RE-PRIORITIZE THINGS.
CAN WE SASHAY?
COME ON, Y'ALL, 'CAUSE YOU ALL
WILL BE DOING THIS IN LONDON.
WORK IT OUT,
WORK IT OUT.
RIGHT NOW, FOR ME, THE WIN
IS A BIT REACHABLE, I THINK.
GOING ABROAD, THAT MEANS IT'S
GETTING REALLY CLOSE
TO THE END
AND WE'RE ALL GONNA
HAVE TO SERIOUSLY STEP IT UP.
WE'RE GOING TO LONDON!
COMING UP
ON "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
KIM'S PENCHANT FOR GOSSIP
GETS OUT OF CONTROL.
I FEEL LIKE
SHE TALKS ABOUT EVERYBODY.
I'VE HEARD PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT ME.
IT'S BEEN LEAD BY KIM.
THIS TIME HER CATTINESS
BLOWS UP IN HER FACE.
YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT
EVERYBODY IN THIS HOUSE.
WHEN I FOUND OUT YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING ALL THIS -- ABOUT ME
ALL THIS TIME, HOW DO YOU THINK
THAT MAKES ME FEEL?
♪♪♪